[Applause]
first of all they don't usually do that
long you were amazing
thank you it's a beautiful beautiful set
probably one of the nicest sets I've
ever been on but here's the thing so
we're actually talking to a couple cops
and I know that you do a lot like how
about your community and yours I think
that that's an amazing thing you want
everything to be peaceful it would be
great you want to be able to be
respected and and is that a big thing
for you like yeah actually coming from
Chicago yeah totally so I work with this
I found it this nonprofit in Chicago
called social works and our main focus
is youth so youth education and like
civics like making sure that their
schools are funded so we actually
donated a million dollars a couple years
ago and what it's actually it started to
like kind of funnel out into a bunch of
other things so now we deal with
homeless population homeless and
transient population and then also
mental health has been a big thing so I
donated a million dollars to mental
health last year we can all be affected
by it personally but also just like in
the way that our families operating like
when we find out how close that I could
hit to home it just lets you know your
proximity to it as much closer than you
think so yeah that's why I got involved
in that's always been important to me I
think that's amazing man you're just not
you but your girl had another baby right
yes
that's that's that's three females in
your house yeah that's a lot of estrogen
yeah a lot of girl in it there's a lot
of female empowerment going on in your
house do you feel like the odd man out
sometimes I think it's a it's good to
have that because I you know as a dude I
hang out with mostly dudes and we get
very like stinky and like loud and stuff
all the time it's good to come home and
just have like a whole bunch of like
princesses that are just like not stinky
or loud why is that so chance cuz I have
been on a bus with boys as well and
that's why generally stay on my own bus
now what is it with men on tour and like
they is if is a shower offensive we just
can't like help ourselves I don't know
what it is if what it is but yeah we
just thank all right and I actually love
this because you pushed you push like
going back on tour because of paternity
leave yeah from a woman that's had
children your wife loves your hair cuz
being left at home with all of that is a
lot yeah I mean when I went on to it
right after my oldest was born I think
like three years ago I went on two or
two weeks after she was born and so that
was like the time that our mom really
really needed my help and now we got two
kids which if anybody doesn't know is
way harder than having one kid there's a
lot of demand for attention and just but
yeah overall overall it's a overwhelming
experience for both of us and I can't
imagine what it would be like fer I have
to do that by herself so yeah I'm crazy
my mom was a single mom and I always
look at that and I'm like what I
wouldn't fear that I don't even know
what I'd have been yeah but here's the
thing - I love your love story I just
recently heard about your love story and
how you met your wife and then how later
in life and happy can you do a quick
synopsis yeah cuz this week quick story
people love to hear this story
so my mother used to work at a real
estate agency from my wife's mother and
they basically would throw these office
parties that they would all bring their
- and one time I went to one and they
were doing a Destiny's Child dance and I
saw her and I was like I like what I see
so then I didn't see it for about let's
just say a long time about ten years and
we met each other at a festival and it
feels good but yeah we saw each other
and hit it off and then we started
dating and then we had Kinsley and then
we got married and now we have Marly and
[Applause]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this